this is Saki Shamir from Rishon LeZion
is real and he has a very very tiny
cannon
and he scored almost 4 million hits with
a very powerful very tiny cannon
I am dubious about how genuine this
video is so is it real time to ask our
scientists this cannon works on exactly
the same principle that all large
cannons work on which is that you have a
cannon ball and you have gunpowder when
gunpowder burns it produces a lot of
gases and all of these gases are trapped
behind the Cannonball and want to expand
and expands they do and this rapidly
increases the pressure behind the
Cannonball the only way that this
pressure can be released is by leaving
the cannon it can only do this by
pushing the Cannonball out of the cannon
at really high speed that ball ended up
traveling at 2,000 km/h 1,200 miles per
hour that's almost a speeding bullet no
wonder it causes destruction if you are
firing a handgun you wouldn't be
surprised to see those results why
should it be any different coming out of
a tiny cannon
so it's just as real as a small handgun
and it proves one thing it's not the
size of the cannon that's important
it's how powerful it is